tabasco sauce mike nolan's eye had to
take a break from his press conference
but he did return and the eye i am happy
to report
is fine the cowboys aren't uh and there
may be one or more members of the
organization who make an appearance in
today's draft the goats in a bad way for
week seven i don't see a trivia question
is there a trivia i got it yep i got it
right here who's got it all right go
ahead fire away all right so let me see
here i don't know this is a confusing
text here all right justin herbert
became the second rookie qb to throw
three tds in consecutive games okay the
second rookie qb to throw three straight
t and three consecutive games three tds
and three consecutive games can you name
one of the others
this is true
chargers rookie it's horrible by our
producer here horrible texting justin
herbert became
the second rookie quarterback
to throw three touchdowns and three
consecutive games all right can you name
the other chargers rookie quarterback
that did that
yeah uh
the second chargers i you said you're
all right spike i don't know yet he
messed it up matt casey drew brees uh no
breeze nope it was ryan leaf i guess i
don't know what the hell matt casey do
he's a jets fan you know what can you
expect from the guy he's you know he's
he's obviously a bad life decision right
off the bat so you know what can we say
let me just say this let me just say
this none of us is getting the last
minute of our lives back i'm sorry sorry
go ahead first pick goes to you it goes
to me
is that even fair um
i guess i gotta go with todd gurley for
goats of the week i mean
i i hate to do it to him he's smart
we've seen him go down before in these
scenarios
um that was a killer there it really was
and and of course i'm sure he's beaten
himself over it as well but the fact
that he did not go down
gave detroit the ability
or he did he did not go down he scores
the touchdown it gives detroit the
ability to go and get the game-winning
touchdown uh that to me has got to be
the goat of the week with todd gurley
but still one of the all-time great
sports photos not quite muhammad ali and
sunny liston but
the lions player
hands in the air
saying touchdown for the other team
because that was the only path to
victory for the detroit lions and it
ultimately worked out lions win falcons
lose just another way you know the
falcons were out of ways to lose games
credit to them for finding another way
to blow a lead and lose a game scoring a
touchdown when you're trying not to
jamie collins says touchdown yes it was
lions win yeah that's that's all time
goat sorry todd but you shouldn't have
scored it was up to you you could have
fallen down in the field of play like
another guy did unintentionally on
thursday night you didn't and that's
what happens all right first one for me
uh i gotta go cam newton i mean god yeah
we've been talking about it it's clear
it's obvious he knows it he wouldn't be
mad about it how could you be mad about
it right it was a horrible performance
in a big spot and now he's left picking
up the pieces the team has left picking
up the pieces and who knows whether or
not they even can
and and who knows how long he'll survive
as the starting quarterback he got
yanked for jared stidham and he
understands that if this continues it
will be permanent not like kirk cousins
with that baloney i'll get eventually
bench for good it's sean mannion
belichick will do it it's jared stidham
at some point he'll do it and cam newton
deserves to have the goat horns for this
week yeah well is
i i get it i mean it's it's been sloppy
the last two weeks we've seen some
errant throws saw some good throws in
the game too but saw some throws where
you just go man that's not cam newton
and he's been off ever since he's gotten
back from cobia 19 so i i get it there
i i think the next one i got to go do
here is um i got to do something with
the defensive staff i think on the the
houston texans in a little bit we just
showed that clip of you know rogers and
devonte adams and you know man-to-man
he's going to keep feeding the feeding
the beast you know it's what i should
have said about russell wilson and dk
metcalf and our last thing you got
man-to-man you guys got to feed him but
romeo cornell and uh i'm blanking on the
damn defense of uh the new defensive
coordinator down there and i'm trying to
look it up right now on the fly and i'm
i'm blanking anthony weaver there it is
i just don't know at what point do you
start to go wait we need to readjust the
game plan what we're doing is not
working you know don't just keep beating
your head against the wall and think
you're getting a different result at
some point just change it up take a
chance do something else but when aaron
rodgers sees devonte adams one on one
against a bunch of guys that can't cover
one-on-one very good
he's gonna tear them apart and he's the
ultimate like if it ain't broke don't
fix it and i'll wear this out and he
wore it out and i just i'm shocked that
there was never an adjustment there from
uh romeo or anthony weaver there to kind
of take damonte adams out of the
football game
i gotta go daniel jones with my next
pick i have to i'm sorry and i've gotten
some emails from people saying oh we're
all human we all make mistakes yeah we
do and that's what this segment of the
show is reserved for the people who make
the most
significant and noteworthy mistakes and
you know it's not just for falling down
in the open field when you have an
87-yard touchdown run probably the only
time in your career you're ever going to
do that but he did fall down in the open
field he did i'm sorry he did and maybe
i would have done the same damn thing
and i would expect it to be included in
this draft in fact i would have been
disappointed if i wasn't included in
this draft but also on top of it you
know that that ongoing lack of awareness
in the pocket yeah i got you going back
to the last play
when he did not take a deep drop he's
waiting for someone to get open and he's
oblivious to the fact that brandon
graham is bearing down on him he's just
oblivious at times and it's like he
doesn't even recognize that there's a
chance that there's going to be somebody
there who may hit him right so uh so
anyway uh daniel jones no i'll answer
you're up next i i well i i get it i do
i mean the the the awareness on the last
play it is annoying and a guy that you
know i'm a giants fan and i root for
daniel jones because he does do a lot of
good things too with not a lot of help
around him but that damn that's
something he can fix fix and uh damn he
needs to fix that because it is an issue
the other thing too i do get a little
sick of people ragging on the guy i know
he tripped and fell but i also want to
like question some of these fan bases
and be like can your quarterback run 80
yards because i don't think they can
i think they might have tripped that
but but i get it he's a professional
athlete more spectacular yeah he's a
professional athlete he's got nothing
but green in front of him it's more
spectacular when who it's it's our
greatest fear
a pratfall in a public setting so when
it happens yeah i mean now you're making
me feel bad for picking the guy good you
should feel bad what a jerk you are all
right yep you're you're a jerk all right
all right you're up
i'm i'm a tough one here you know i
think i think i'm gonna go
and i don't like to do this because i'm
going to the other new york quarterback
i'm going to go to sam darnold all right
and i'm really only because of one play
and we you know we talked about it on
football night in america but it's a
10-3 lead
the end of the first half
they're dancing around midfield
and he throws a bad interception into
double coverage along the left sideline
and that was like night night the game
was over it really was buffalo got a
quick field goal before the half ended
they got the ball to start the second
half they went down and kicked another
field goal and all of a sudden the jets
were losing the football game are only
up by one excuse me but you know again i
know he doesn't have a lot of help it's
just one of those things where you go
man you got a 10-3 lead the other team's
struggling a little don't give them any
life don't do anything see the big
picture of the game you guys aren't good
you're not the type of like oh you're
gonna make some crazy play type offense
right here to get one more field goal or
whatever that is so that was uh maybe
their chance
to win a game last week they caught the
bills on an off week for sure who have
not been playing well and they kind of
had them wobbly on the ropes and i feel
like that kind of woke the bills up a
little bit and got them going again
last one for me
and and this one just occurred to me
because i've got several others because
you didn't you only picked one of the
ones because i come with six yeah in the
event that you have the three that i
also jumped up you know you know the
math goes sometimes sometimes i live
dangerously and i have fewer than six
today you only took one that i took i'm
gonna go john bostic though and i didn't
even bring that one to the table but it
just it just was reminded i forgot about
it i think in that cowboys game i was
thinking mike mccarthy yeah thinking
no right you know what john bostic
applied a gratuitous unnecessary violent
hit that has no place in today's game
it never had a place
in the guy was sliding he went in helmet
first he blew up andy dalton he gave him
a concussion there was no need for it
it's not like you're trying to knock you
know the greatest quarterback in
football out of the game for strategic
reasons so you can win the super bowl
again not that i'm saying that any of
that's ever right but at least in that
setting you benefit what do you what's
the benefit at that point there's no
strategic benefit
and again that doesn't make it right i'm
just saying it makes it even more
gratuitous and unnecessary and head
scratching that in that moment when they
are dominating the cowboys that he would
feel compelled to apply that kind of a
hit to andy dalton as ron rivera told me
after the game he's a veteran player he
told him you should know better he
should know better he isn't suspended
for it he was ejected i'm sure he'll get
a huge fine and if he ever does anything
like that again he should be suspended
for multiple games chris yeah yeah i
mean we're just we're too i mean you
said it right there really was never any
place for that you know but especially
not now i mean after the last eight ten
years with all this conversation and the
way the league's gone and
the guys are too informed you get to see
too many videos all year long about what
you should and what you shouldn't do let
alone the coaches themselves stay on you
that way so
yeah i'm with that was a good call mike
and i can't lie i forgot about that one
i did so uh good one there uh i'm gonna
i think i got what go ahead well we
gotta go yeah i'm gonna go nick last
night isn't it my pick or that i've been
already done i'm done no you've already
done three okay well i want to add nick
foles on there but too late sorry i'm
good last friday last friday peter king
very seamlessly just blew right into
round four so we had a four round round
that was that shocker i'm really shocked
was he like we're all right all right my
fourth round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports